si usted sufre de obesidad severa y no
ha podido perder peso su médico puede
recomendarle una cirugía bariátrica
robótica
su sistema digestivo o tracto
gastrointestinal
incluye boca
esófago
estómago
intestino delgado
e intestino grueso
su páncreas
hígado
y vesícula biliar libera jugos
digestivos en su intestino delgado para
ayudar a descomponer el alimento que
usted come
su médico puede recomendar cirugía
bariátrica si no puede perder peso y
mantiene el peso a pesar de dietas y
ejercicios tiene un índice de masa
corporal o imc por encima de 40 tiene un
imc por encima de 35 y tiene una
condición que amenaza a su vida tal como
diabetes o enfermedad cardíaca o pesa
más de 100 libras 45 kilos por encima de
su peso corporal ideal
wv
la cirugía bariátrica lo ayuda a perder
peso disminuyendo el tamaño de su
estómago para que conserven menos
alimento y se sienta satisfecho más
rápidamente
su procedimiento puede incluir un bypass
en alguna parte de su intestino delgado
para disminuir la longitud del camino
del alimento a través del sistema
digestivo así como la cantidad de
calorías absorbidas del alimento
antes del procedimiento se colocará una
vía intravenosa
usted puede recibir antibióticos vía
intravenosa para disminuir la
posibilidad de infecciones se le
administrara anestesia general se le
insertará un tubo respiratorio por la
boca y en la tráquea para ayudarle a
respirar durante la operación
su cirujano realizará una pequeña
incisión cerca de su ombligo e insertará
un tubo plástico llamado puerto se
bombeará gas dióxido de carbono a su
abdomen a través de este puerto
el gas inflar a su abdomen lo que le
dará al cirujano más espacio para ver y
mover las herramientas quirúrgicas
después de inflar su abdomen se
insertará una cámara de alta definición
en este puerto
su cirujano realizará incisiones
adicionales del puerto para instrumentos
robóticos así como para instrumentos
usados por los asistentes que se
encuentran junto al paciente
un asistente insertará todas las
herramientas robóticas por estos puertos
a diferencia de los instrumentos
laparoscópicos estándar estas
herramientas pueden rotar 360 grados y
tienen mayor flexibilidad que la muñeca
humana
sentado en una consola especial su
cirujano operara los brazos robóticos y
la cámara con controles tipo joystick y
pedales a pie
una computadora traducir a los
movimientos exactos de los dedos de su
cirujano en movimientos precisos de las
herramientas quirúrgicas
a la vez un sistema de visión de alta
definición ofrecerá una vista
estereoscópica aumentada en tres
dimensiones del área quirúrgica
dos procedimientos quirúrgicos
bariátricos robóticos comunes son el
bypass gástrico y la banda gástrica
ajustable
si usted va a realizarse un
procedimiento de banda gástrica
ajustable su cirujano aplicará una banda
restrictiva alrededor de su estómago
para limitar la cantidad de alimento que
su estómago puede recibir un tubo
conectará la banda a un puerto justo
debajo de la piel de su abdomen
su cirujano inyectará una solución
salina en el tubo para ajustar las
rigidez de la banda según sea necesario
para acelerar la pérdida de peso o
reducir los efectos colaterales
si usted va a realizarse un
procedimiento de bypass gástrico su
cirujano creará una pequeña bolsa en su
estómago y la separará del resto de su
estómago y la parte superior de su
intestino delgado
la sección inferior de su intestino
delgado se unirá a la bolsa del estómago
y luego su cirujano volverá a unir la
sección superior de su intestino delgado
a una parte diferente de su intestino
delgado inferior lo que permitirá que
los jugos digestivos de su páncreas
hígado y vesícula biliar ayuden a
digerir los alimentos
al final de cualquier de los dos
procedimientos se cerrarán las pequeñas
incisiones con puntos de sutura grapas
pegamento quirúrgico o con vendajes de
cierre
después del procedimiento se les
retirará el tubo respiratorio y se le
trasladará al área de recuperación para
controlarlo le darán medicamentos para
el dolor si fuese necesario
usted puede continuar recibiendo
antibióticos por vía intravenosa la
mayoría de los pacientes son dados de
alta del hospital uno o dos días después
del procedimiento